All these emotes, wondering how to spell that
Now we're older, everyone's moved on
But I remember Twitch chat
When those who have gone Twitch go home, so go go, made you feel you're not alone
Captain PogChamp, go for me
BibleThumb, Twitch emotes, I remember
Typing dance games, forehead swift rage, PJ Salt and failfish
Life was easy, spamming all the time
TOS was nowhere, so everyone
Twitch emotes, from long ago
Made you feel you're not alone
Captain PogChamp, keep up forehead
BibleThumb, Twitch emotes
Still hear his bark in the morning hour, he calls me
His doggy emote reminds me of a time far away
Looking at a chat, I get a feeling that I've missed emotes from yesterday
Yesterday
Twitch emotes, from long ago
Made you feel you're not alone
Pog is PogChamp, Cap is CapBug
BibleThumb, Twitch emotes
Pepehands, Twitch emotes
Youtube
Twitch